well the governor's restrictions on bars
were just some of the changes that he
called for and then they'll begin this
weekend
but he's also taking aim at pools and
water parks places he says have really
been lacking in both
mass usage and also social distancing
kirsten joyce is here now to explain
denise not all casino hotel pools and
water park
water parks that is across our state
that have been checked have been
following the governor's mandate
and here is his message to everyone when
you are at
a water park or a hotel pool i want to
be crystal clear
unless you are actively walking into a
pool
swimming in a pool or walking out of a
pool
you should have a face covering on at
all times
it's as simple as that governor siselek
says he will continue to monitor
compliance and evaluate and take action
as necessary
we reached out to wet wild for comment
and the company got back to us today
saying it has been meeting and exceeding
safety mandates set in place
it has taken a wide range of precautions
to encourage social distancing
requiring temperature checks for all its
members and guests and requires all
staff to wear face masks
wet and wild also says in part as with
similar businesses in nevada
water park guests are not required to
wear mass while in the water
and enjoying the parks rides and
attractions cowabunga bay also shared
with us today that it has had
several visits from the city of
henderson and southern nevada health
district
and each time says its park has been in
compliance with new guidelines
this is video of before the park opened
the park is now enforcing the guidelines
with a three-step procedure
signage posted throughout recordings
that play every 15 minutes reminding
guests of the protocols
and with added security walking around
to remind guests
state officials are asking employees who
want to make a complaint against any
business to file them
online at osha.gov